[Music]
and hello there news
submitted by why does Joe always have an
instrument no I'm not yes he does
oh that gets all the [ __ ] yeah you
don't even have costumes you're changing
dude what happened what happened you
getting hot actually you need that extra
[ __ ] anymore when you get hot you got a
drop all that you don't need it will
never be hot in my life ever you needs
to stay this [ __ ] costumes and play
with those shoes get on you know though
you Lena
what thank you bar at least some people
notice in the fitness industry that
understand body and physique teen
stumble upon a dying man who was trapped
in a hole for wheat oh what the [ __ ]
what is that like The Grudge in the well
what do you remember that one wait was
it the dream or the ring the ring at I
think oh yeah it's the big start what
stood between The Grudge in the ring
wanders in the closet and one is in the
whale
yeah the same thing it's a creepy kid
right yeah I took a girl that got
traumatized no no the grudge's she was a
mistress and then the well one she was
just a kid that cuz the grudge was
attached to a home like it's a specific
home yeah what was she like a mistress
though the girl that has like that I
don't remember all I know is that [ __ ]
came outside of somebody's the back side
of somebody's head during the shower you
have any idea how hard it is to shower a
shampoo with your eyes open
yeah when I found out about Bloody Mary
I [ __ ] avoided the bathroom and shower
for like a week straight do you know how
hard it is to try not to take a [ __ ] or
shower I think that's why I probably
didn't shower for a long long time it
probably started from there what did you
do did your mom happen to find out yeah
word I dragged my mom in the bathroom
with me and I was like there's [ __ ]
evil spirits in there I'd guarantee you
gotta watch me take a [ __ ] I just got
scared cuz I did it and nothing happened
I was like she's gonna come later it's
just that right now that's what I
thought I opened up Pandora's box it's
not happening now but it might happen
later yes I know I know but at this
point now I'm older so I'm like I'm
hoping
know that she's nice and we could talk
what if like it was just a woman on her
period you don't even like Bloody Mary
is Jess okay so this is Isaac he's 19
look like but it's not very interesting
me it's like I okay yeah yeah yes it
looks very bad no facial hair it doesn't
grow up right it's too thin it looks
like a boy with facial hair oh it's like
baby hair he's a sweet kid it's just
natural he looks like he sells
newspapers
yes good evening sir would you like your
morning paper he looks like a very nice
young yeah who saved someone's life
mm-hmm so he's a hero so Isaac was with
his friend Emily and they were actually
in England and they were in the woods
course you were try to save them
so Wow like a harry potter and the
sorcerer's bone well I'm saying well I
think and Emily we're walking through
the woods [ __ ] do the woods hey no no
no walking through the woods they
discovered this whole like somewhere in
the wood is that the same Isaac is that
Isaac yeah that's the same just got a
hole that's a [ __ ] castle you don't
discover bullets a building the tunnel
it's a really nice picture it's a great
picture so let me know sources are
referring it to as a whole or to like a
chamber even some of them are referring
it to a cape I'm just gonna refer it to
a whole but what I'm saying it's not
like a whole it's it's wow so it's that
the term is a chamber bricks did not
form by a tornado in nature and all the
cement just glued it all together man
manmade manmade whole man okay so he
didn't stumble upon anything there's a
[ __ ] building in the middle of woods
she stumbled upon a man-made hole
alright it looks like a tunnel okay so
he was okay let's be real so he's trying
to find a place to function he saw this
abandoned building and he found the hole
that he could [ __ ] in he thought you
know I'm right either way they found
that see you I abandon that made whole
tunnel whatever you guys would like to
call it where you put the come
afterwards just shoot it on the ground
that's so nasty what if there's some
kids on a field trip like looking at
this historical place and they they go
teacher watch this son I would like peep
and they made a tasty historical place
at a whole you know who it's not a hole
it's a tunnel I think the point is that
we should hear this damn story so he saw
this hole and so he went he actually
climbed inside and he was just like like
saying like hello right just so he can
hear his echo back right like the dear
old Wendy when he so I feel like
climbing in he was actually telling
Emily's like hey Emily do you want to
join me right did you see it like
everyone's like nah I don't want to join
you because like it's scary I don't know
what's in there right it's a white
people [ __ ] that's why exactly exact
same thing that Asian black person or
Mexican person would have done that [ __ ]
they all love to investigate I know
[ __ ] you did a home ok white people's
like it's dangerous here should we
pursue it further speak right into a
deceiver animal comes out mr. lion lion
lion so I think the whole and you wanted
to so he was trying to say hello and get
an echo back right so he can scare Emily
right so after climbing into one hold
okay I'm not getting anything right so
he discovers like another hole why does
he keep [ __ ] messing with fate and
[ __ ] dude you survived the first two
ones you're good oh well okay so he
climbed into another hole and he started
saying hello right and then when he said
hello he heard something that he thought
might have been his echo and so he said
hello a few more times and then he heard
like a different reply Hey yeah and so
at that time hello
that freaked me the [ __ ] out and then
I'll never talk about it again I
wouldn't think it's a guy he's a ghost
I would think it's a demon trying to not
what he said I feel like finally it's
Bloody Mary mommy I don't think you're
too far off because then when he heard
that he like got scared because it was
all dark in there so he couldn't see
what else was so he went in further so
they're like so you're not too far off
because like he got freaked out because
like um he heard this echo and he didn't
know what else to do because just
looking inside the hole like it was dark
right and so he just quickly ran out he
went up to Emily and it was like hey
Ellie I think I hear somebody inside
these tough like inside this hole right
and then a Great Plague I don't believe
you right just don't try to scare
me that's the beginning of a scary movie
- white people not believing each other
sounds like a perfect movie to me and so
for proof what he did is like he ran
back down to where the hole was and he
decided to report it to prove el mero
always during daytime yeah okay how do I
prove you ad your I you that would
figure pay is really mouthful where's
all right um so pretty much like he just
needs some water like I wouldn't be
saying I'm tasty I couldn't make out
from it but he was able to hear this dog
this pretty much someone replying though
what the [ __ ] are you saying that yeah
if you're gonna record just continue and
just keep the camera straight don't
[ __ ] stop running like this
now respect that he was not in worldstar
mode he's like no I'm not gonna go
actually help somebody until I take my
iPhone so how did the first white guy
fallen okay so
so yes before I get to that Isaac runs
back up to where Elias and he sees like
two joggers go by and so he asked the
joggers for help but the joggers are too
afraid to go into the hole so eventually
like they got people to like come in and
rescue 51 your boys 51 year old and your
old James what was James doing in there
how come the other fool has a fly-ass
photo his photo sucks ass he's 51 years
old he was watching [ __ ] gay porn or
something hiding from his wife so
apparently I was water the only they're
just like call 9-1-1 get the police yeah
yeah cuz if I'm like dying I don't think
it the first thing I say do you do do
you have some ginger ale you guys
haven't been hella thirsty then cuz
thirst is the number one basic instinct
did you say water first well food water
shelter or like thirst so when you are
thirsty like that it's all you care
about I would have drank that sooner
water
why do you get in there year yeah so
apparently James has been missing for
about a month
what oh my god he's been living out in
the woods and so for him well that's his
fault that he purposely wanted to remove
himself from society no wonder he just
wanted water he wants to be in the woods
and he thought that guy was like a
waiter or something yes I'll take your
water and also some more butter please
you can't be like a Abbas's outside
society you can't like build a house
it's like solar-powered like live on
your own like they just out lock out the
gray yeah you can't do that no not
supposed to because the government needs
to keep track of your body then being
homeless it's not cuz he's still on the
[ __ ] grid you still there James
apparently was missing for about a month
but in the reports they believe that
James was actually stuck in that hole
for at least a week and a half
what about the other three I guess yeah
but I just don't understand yeah
just stuck in there so apparently like
um he got into the hole when he suddenly
hurt his ankle
yeah you mean he fell and hurt is he
hurt his ankle and then he fell cuz it
sounds like well you know he broke his
arm and then [ __ ] transported into
the hole yeah this is the picture where
they found it at the bottom of the hole
oh he ate [ __ ] hard like scary dude he
landed on all those sticks and those
sharp wood so what what I'm a Sumerian
night but he was living in the woods for
a month yeah well he expect what did he
eat like how did you see yeah yeah I
think it was two weeks without water
that means he was on the brink of death
and like doctors did say that you know
if any more day of course of course they
always say that come to the hospital in
the next two hours you would have been
dead always say that that same line it's
it's that hospital marketing yeah you
know make you understand how much you
need them it's like oh you're glad you
came just in time all this we'll need it
was some like Gatorade coconut water
coconut water
revitalize his [ __ ] thirst throw some
coconuts down there yeah just when you
leave somewhere you gotta always make
sure people know where you had to always
unless you want to die they okay how's
it going guys don't forget to like the
video because if you don't I will break
your [ __ ] legs thank you so much for
the last video don't forget to click
right here or I'll break your [ __ ]
arms click right here guys
[Music]